Speaker 1: Jorge Santos is now admitting
to another possible crime, and this one
requires a bit of an explanation. Business
Insider reports George Santos hints that the
$500,000 personal loan to his own campaign wasn't
his own money. Now, that raises questions as to
whether that violated campaign finance law. He may
be effectively admitting to a crime George Santos
made significant. By the way, this is George
Anthony Katara divulged there. Santos That's the
person we're talking about. George Santos made
significant revisions to campaign finances on
Tuesday, per The Daily Beast. The amended filings
reveal that a $500,000 personal loan to his 2022
campaign wasn't personally funded. Experts
say the amended filings add to the mystery of
Santos questionable financial disclosures. So the
initial filing showed a box for personal funds of
the candidate for that big loan. The amended
filing did not check that. It also doesn't
mention the source of the funds. If there was a
guarantor because there's very little information
provided. Another revised filing disclosed that
a separate $125,000 loan from Santos in October
to his campaign is no longer listed as coming from
his personal fund. So this is over $600,000 that
he previously said was my own money. And now it
appears as though it is not. Unless, of course,
this is just an error. Maybe the new filing is
the erroneous one. With Jorge Santos, it's always
hard to know. Was he lying then? Is he lying now?
What's going on? So couple different things here.
First of all, are we aware of anything about his
campaign that isn't fraudulent? I guess it seems
that he really is a gay man, even though even that
was sort of questioned because he was married to a
woman as recently as three years ago. But he says
he was openly gay for a decade. And I want to be
sensitive to that because there are all sorts of
different reasons why someone who is gay might
not be living publicly as a gay person because
of stigma, social pressure, family, whatever.
The confusion is, he says he was living publicly
as a gay man for a decade. So it's all very
confusing, but it at least appears that he really
is a gay man and he has not lied about that. But
beyond that, this is one of the most dishonest
people in every sense. Volleyball star who ended
up needing to have two knee replacements because
of the wear and tear on his knees where he worked.
He was ju as you, I can't even give you the
entire full list. There are some rumblings and.
I mean, we've heard this so many times with Trump,
right? This is it. This is the end of Trump. And
then it never is. There are rumblings that if
indeed it turns out that this was an illegal
campaign contribution from someone else, because
remember, there are different rules about you
loaning your own campaign money versus accepting
contributions this large from other people,
which is not allowed. So there could
be a crime here. There are rumblings
that if it is determined that indeed he did
receive an illegal contribution in this way,
that this could finally be the last
straw. This guy seems to have a similar
resilience as Donald Trump. So I'm going
to withhold judgment for the time being.